so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you what happens when you just sort
of blindly go through we're doing T
results yeah and what happens when you
attempted with this question and
therefore what you can do to try and get
around that because things kinda exploit
a little bit so what I've done is I've
set up over here on the right-hand side
these are all of the results i'm about
to use okay i want to change the
function or change the integrand and i
want to change the variable of
integration so here's my introduction of
the T results as with extension one when
you used to results you've got to say
let t equal please do it even if you've
got it in your head or you just look at
the reference tree please don't jump in
there right like what is this tea
business that you're going about and
sometimes you know what t equals to you
don't want to be tempting or two maybe
you want 10 feet up maybe you want
whatever okay so make sure you define
he's my foot once you've defined it I go
straight to sign because that's what's
relevant to be in this particular degree
and then I go through this that's a
result which I remember but you can
verify it fairly easily and now ready be
good okay so like I said I'm gonna give
this a go just on the face of it and I'm
things as you will see turn long okay or
at least they turned are very helpful so
here's what I'm going to start off with
what have I got on my goober radar well
there's just a regular Scythia so I'll
go no sorry Jude Law there you go
there's the replacement of sine theta
but as well as that I have to replace
the variable go change the variable of
integration so what else part by this on
the new grade are you okay with that so
I've got a two
d t on the feeder and that d thing is
going to cancel shortly so far so good
okay you have a look at this denominator
it doesn't look that different you just
have a 2-0 the front 2 plus and then
I'll get a juice a theater we go d theta
sorry cancel cancel so far so good so
this is just kind of straightforward I'm
using all the solutions are x and i'm
hoping and praying that algebraically
thing's gonna pan out for me right now
before i go much further it looks to me
like i cancel out a factor of two did
you notice that so that'll make things
lesson canceled they canceled their
cancel then that look great so far now
what else can i do near fractions on
fractions suggestions okay so i'm going
to multiply through the numerator and
the denominator says is very place 1
plus t square again that's a good step
and we've seen that happen lots and lots
you will do that repeatedly because it
often is the denominator your sine or
cosine but in this case it won't quite
be enough you don't tell me why yeah
okay so you notice on the denominator if
i multiply through by 1 plus T squared
that will resolve distraction so that
looks good but on the numerator if I
both want my through by a wall post a
square I'll only get rid of one of these
denominators because it's appearing
twice right it's pretty once resign and
one from its derivative so instead of oz
my through once and leave it with
fractions on fractions I'm glad multiply
through twice okay so i'm going to
multiply everything by 1 plus T squared
squared okay what does that leave you
with online you
just to t yeah okay what is it leave you
with all the denominator well this one
will become 1 plus T squared squared and
there's a tea there this one plus T
squared will cancel and there'll be
another 1 plus T Square that comes from
the right how does it look so far how's
my algebra book baby look okay to check
out ok now this point before you go any
further you're starting now have to be
suspicious because what do I do with
this what can I do well what you expand
out and it doesn't take that much to see
you got your Tootsie on the new beretta
what are you getting down the bottom
here this is this is gross right like I
mean I can't take out a factor of what
[ __ ] squared if I like but what that
noise I could say okay I by the way fact
racing is not that bad an idea because
you might think well partial fractions
and go from here it's going to be a bit
of a disaster what happens if i expand
out i'm gonna get to the 4 2t squared
plus 1 plus t plus t cube yeah
what what I do
divide through by T squared so you're
suggesting I'm gonna have to on tape
yeah this will become T squared plus 2
plus 1 on it's not going to it's not
going to take me anywhere helpful not
get a hurry anyway ok so I'm going to
look at this and I'm going to say is
this something else I can do seeing this
maybe suggests i should have changed my
approach or maybe done something before
i just went straight to the T results
Eddie taken subtractive ok so the
problem is and we've seen in fact I
think our previous result I did for you
was this guy for I'm doing this remember
so my coefficients might be slightly on
ok now seen this before this panned out
just fine ok the differences in this at
this is that you have an addition or
trig function which appears up here on
the numerator and that's exactly what
caused our problem here do you notice
that right so you're like ah this turns
into this which turns it to multiply
through by your quartic function and
that's why everything just kind of
unravel make a mess so this is me
identifying what's the problem and
therefore wants a likely solution